Actually, before moving on to
the next problem, sometimes at
the end of a video I really rush
it, just because I have
that silly YouTube 10
minute deadline.
And I want you to really
understand this point here, of
why I picked the negative
2 and the positive 3.
Let me erase some of this and
kind of show you what my
thought process was.
So I'm using the paintbrush
tool.
Let me just blank it all out.
So if I just blank that
out, and I could
actually blank this out.
I'm just blanking
everything out.
I could have just erased
everything, but anyway.
So the possible terms again,
once again, were 0 plus or
minus 2, and 5 plus
or minus 3.
And I want to show you why I
picked the lowest value here,
and the highest value here.
So let me graph those points.
That's my y-axis.
This is my x-axis.
And so, first I have
the point, 0 comma
plus 2 or minus 2.
So this is 0, 2.
This is 0, minus 2.
And then we have 5.
Let's say this is 5 out here.
I'm going to say this
is 3 up here.
This is 5, positive 3, and then
5, negative 3 will be
someplace around here,
just not scaled up.
I have to squeeze at the bottom,
but you get the point.
So there's a bunch of lines that
could connect this whole
set of points, right?
I'm going to do them in
different colors.
You have this line.
And then you have this line.
Well, we want the highest
possible slope.
And you could probably just
inspect it and say, well, the
highest possible slope is the
one that moves up the
steepest. So it'll
be this line.
And this line and this line are
negative slopes, so that's
not a high slope.
And the way I did it,
intuitively, I said, well, in
order to have a high slope,
I want as high a
change in y as possible.
I want to maximize my change
in y, given my change in x.
And that's why I picked the
lowest y and the highest y.
If I wanted the lowest possible
slope, I would have
picked positive 2
and negative 3.
Hopefully that makes a little
bit more sense.
Let's see, let's do
problem number 18.
Esther drove to work in the
morning at an average speed of
45 miles per hour.
45 miles per hour is how
fast Esther drove.
So this is to work.
She returned home in the
evening, along the same route
at an average of 30
miles per hour.
30 miles per hour-- maybe
there was more
traffic-- from work.
If Esther spent a total of one
hour commuting to and from
work, so one hour total, how
many miles did Esther drive to
work in the morning?
So this is a simple distance
is equal to rate
times to time problem.
But it's a little fancy.
It gets a little confusing.
So let's just say that d is
the distance to work.
And then we'll just solve
for d, right?
So if d is the distance to work,
how far did she go in
the morning?
So in the morning we have the
distance she went in the
morning is going to be equal
to 45 miles per hour.
That's the rate.
45 miles per hour
times the time.
So let's just call
that times t.
That's what she did
in the morning.
She went 45 miles an
hour times however
long it took her.
Then in the afternoon, she's
going to go to the same
distance, right?
This time she went 30
miles per hour.
Now, how long did it take her?
Well, this is the interesting
thing.
It took her a total of one
hour to go to work
and back from work.
If it took her t hours in the
morning, then it took her 1
minus t hours.
Actually, let's do
it in minutes.
Let's assume t is in minutes.
So then one hour is 60,
60 minus t minutes.
Actually, I have to stay within
hours, because these
are all miles per hour.
So forgive me.
1 minus t.
Does that make sense?
This one, I think, will
make sense to you.
45 miles per hour times however
many hours she traveled.
It tells you how many
miles she went.
This time you have her speed,
30 miles per hour, times the
time she traveled.
Well, the time she traveled in
the afternoon is going to be
one hour minus whatever she
traveled in the morning.
Because when you combine in the
morning and afternoon, she
traveled for a total
of one hour.
For example, if she took 15
minutes to go in the morning,
then that means it took
her 45 minutes to
come back in the afternoon.
Hopefully that makes sense.
But these are the
same d's, right?
So we could set them equal
to each other.
So we could say 45 times t is
equal to 30 times 1 minus t.
Let me see.
45t is equal to 30 minus 30t.
And then we can add 30t to both
sides and you get 75t is
equal to 30.
Then we get t is equal
to 30/75 hours.
And if we divide the top and
the bottom by 5, we get 6
over-- 5 goes into this
how many times?
Actually, yeah, let
me divide it by 5.
5 goes into 10, 15, right?
I could divide by a better
number than 5.
Actually, I could divide the
top and the bottom by 15.
And you get 2/5.
Or just take this and divide
the top and bottom
by 3, you get 2/5.
So time is equal to 2/5 hours.
That's 24 minutes,
roughly, right?
So we go back to the distance.
And remember, t is how long it
took her in the morning.
In the afternoon, it's going to
be 1 minus this, so in the
afternoon it took her
1 minus this.
This would be 3/5 hours.
The question is, how
many miles did she
go to and from work?
So that's d.
Well, d is 45 times t.
t is 2/5.
45 times 2/5 is d.
It comes to 9, cancel that,
so it comes to 8.
18, I mean.
9 times 2 is 18.
So d is equal to 18 miles.
And we are done, our
second SAT section.
I hope I didn't confuse
you too much.
See you soon.